all right let's go to Brody from Dallas
we love Brody from Dallas he always has
something interesting from for me we
haven't heard from him for a little over
two months Brody what's going on my
friend oh man I've just been super busy
how you doing man good doing well all
right so I actually wanted to dive into
something that hasn't been touched on
the debates and I wanted to get your
perspective on it being the brilliant
economist right and it's that we've seen
we've seen a lot of and rightly so we've
seen a lot of focus on college and
post-secondary education student loans
tuition and debt and how that obviously
has an effect on our economy and a
variety of different and great proposals
by many candidates and we've heard some
mentioned that headstart and pre-k I
wanted to know what you thought about is
if we're not diving in deep enough into
the focus on essentially reforming our
funding formula for schools because as
you know most areas get it from property
taxes and contribute to inequality yeah
lots of bad things what are some
suggestions that you might have come
across or any depressive ideas that you
might promote or look suggest people
look into in terms of their own
communities for a better funding formula
and what are some opportunities there's
I mean listen it needs to be done
systemically unless there's you know
you're not going to do it with bake
sales and fund raisers I think is the
idea so at a certain point it needs to
be are we just going to be funding
education through property taxes and and
often it's not just property taxes it's
a combination of state funds distributed
often on a per population basis combined
with property taxes are we just going to
do that or are we going to do some kind
of what might be called like a special
assessment or an override of some kind
and at the city and town level when I
was growing up in Northampton
Massachusetts there were often
initiatives ballot initiatives about do
we want to do another half point on
property taxes over the next however
long but the the more novel approach
would be instead of doing it as an
addition to prop
tax look at some version of what
Elizabeth Warren or Bernie Sanders are
talking about in terms of a wealth tax
now I know in the past I've said legally
this may be complicated and I'm not
backing up on that I'm just saying it's
an idea look at using some kind of rat
rather than tacking it on to property
tax where it will affect middle-class
homeowners that can't really afford to
pay more look at doing some kind of a
very very high net worth either wealth
tax or income tax or something like that
and you know the political viability of
it is a question mark obviously but it's
got to be more you it's not going to be
able to be bake sales and fundraisers
right it's got to be centralizing yeah
you're right we could we actually have
existing things like title one that
would also if those funds do and did you
have any specific thoughts on in terms
of like little good that they divorced
in your advocacy of charter schools and
you've made a really good point that the
money follows the student do you think
that a central funding formula from the
national government or a larger
organization would help eliminate some
of the problems that we see with charter
schools that is going to create an S
storm of states rightists saying whoa
whoa whoa hold on a second that's not
the way you can do it so I mean it's
it's certainly possible but I don't see
it as being successful in any kind of
medium-term way right on that I just
wanted to get your opinion on that
because we're focusing on college and
the higher education is great but I just
wanted to hear some opinions and talk
about local funding formulas very good
Brody I'm hearing an accent today that I
haven't noticed from you before are you
from like Pennsylvania New Jersey some
somewhere in there I'm actually from
California oh I've got really bad yeah
I've got really bad congestion today
from the terrible allergies here got it
okay that might have been it
all right Brody very good good to hear
from you okay take it easy we'll take a
quick break don't hang up if you're
holding because we will go right back to
the phone's just after this short break